VISION
Wanda?
WANDA MAXIMOFF
Hmm?
VISION
Is there something special about today?
WANDA MAXIMOFF
Well, I know the apron is a bit much dear,
but I am doing my
best to blend in.
[Laughter]
VISION
No, no, there on the calendar.
Someone’s drawn a little heart
right above today’s date.
WANDA MAXIMOFF
Oh yes, the heart.
VISION
Hmm...
WANDA MAXIMOFF
Well don’t tell me you’ve forgotten, Vis?
VISION
Forgotten? Oh Wanda, I’m incapable
of forgetfulness. I remember everything,
and that’s not an exaggeration.
In fact, I’m incapable
of exaggeration.
WANDA MAXIMOFF
Well then tell me what’s so important
about today’s date?
[Laughter]
VISION
What was the question again?
Oh well, perhaps you
have forgotten yourself.
WANDA MAXIMOFF
Me? Heavens no!
I’ve been so looking
forward to it.
VISION
As have I! Today, we’re celebrating...
WANDA MAXIMOFF
You bet we are. It’s the first time we...
VISION
Mmhmm...
WANDA MAXIMOFF
...have ever celebrated
this occasion before.
VISION
It’s a special day!
WANDA MAXIMOFF
Perhaps an evening.
VISION
Of great significance.
WANDA MAXIMOFF
To us both.
VISION
Naturally.
WANDA MAXIMOFF
Obviously.
VISION
Exactly.
[Laughter]
VISION
Well done us.